hi I'm Carmen and I'm going to be
talking about certification today uh
this is Joint work with these wonderful
people uh guy Blanc Caleb Koch Jane Lang
and the young tan so let's get to it
um all right what's our motivation here
we want to explain the behavior of black
boxes what does that mean uh we have
query access to some unknown function f
we put it in X
um this black box spins out in f of x
and we don't know why
um so our goal is given a specific input
a specific input X star we want to
explain why F outputs what it does on
um x-star uh there's a lot of interest
in answering this question from the
explainable machine Learning Community
um you can imagine why it might be
um interesting for machine learning
people
uh machine learning models are often
quite opaque and so being able to come
up with simple explanations for why a
model does what it does could be quite
useful
um
we focus on local explanations meaning
we explain F's behavior on a specific
input X star uh contrast this with
trying to explain F's
behavior in general we just care about
the the local X star
so in this talk we'll be giving new
algorithms and lower bounds for this
problem
uh there are many ways to formulize this
problem so we'll just be giving one
uh we will be using certificates ads
explanations so here's the formal
definition we'll be using
um if there's a function f uh and an
input X star a certificate for F's value
a nice star is a set s of coordinates of
X star
um subset if F if Y and X star agree on
these coordinates then F of Y and f of x
star should agree
uh in other words fixing the coordinates
of s to match X star should render the
function constant
so if we're using certificates adds our
explanations naturally we want a simple
explanation or equivalently a short
certificate
we write cert sub f of x star to denote
the sides of the smallest certificate
for f on a specific input X star and we
Define the certificate complexity to be
cert of f to be the maximum of sort of
sub f of x for the worst input X
so it's the length of the shortest
certificate for the worst X we're taking
a maximum of a minimum here
so some background on this problem
um certificate complexity is
extensively studied in complexity Theory
as it's a highly natural measure of
Boolean function complexity
um it's studied in learning theory and
there are classic algorithms for finding
small certificate for a restricted set
of functions given by Valiant and anguin
and it's also
um highly relevant for explainable
machine learning as I said before uh
here's a small example of certification
uh suppose you have an algorithm that
decides whether an image is a dog who
you can see our input X star is this
picture of a dog and the function
it's spinning out yes indeed this is a
dog
um so here is a certificate S for S
value on X star you can see it's just a
subset of the of the input bit of X star
the input pixels in this case
um and so you might imagine that this
this black box F doesn't care about the
background it only cares about like the
dog's head and that's enough too and a
few other details and that's enough to
determine that yes this is in fact a dog
so
um just to illustrate further that this
is a certificate we can change the other
pixels uh however we want and it still
will be a certificate we will um we can
put the dog underwater and install a dog
we can put the dog in in a gym and it's
still a dog
uh and so on
so now we're ready to formally State the
algorithmic problem that we're
considering
giving queries to a function f with a
certificate complexity less than or
equal to K and an input I star we want
to Output small certificates for F's
value on X star and here by small I mean
size polity k
so here's what I've just said here's
what I just said Illustrated we have an
input x a black box f
um and we're able to make queries to
that we're given a promise that it's
certificate complexity isn't too large
and we're given X star and all we want
to do is output sides poly k a size poly
K certificate S for S value on X star
so the bad news first
forget trying to find a certificate
even checking whether a set s is indeed
a certificate it's co-mp complete
so say that you've been able to solve
our algorithmic problem you said yes I I
have this polycase certificate for S
value on X star even checking whether or
not you've actually solved the problem
is co and P complete
also assuming p is not equal to NP we
cannot efficiently find a certificate
besides V of K for any growth function
fee so forget Paul AK think of fee as 2
to the K to the K to the k no matter how
rapidly fee grows with k
um we still can't find a certificate of
that size
okay
um so given intractability what do we do
prior work has focused on
circumventing intractability by making
assumptions on the function in
particular
um
they've made it the assumption that the
function should be monotone so Valiant
and anguin give simple and gives a
simple and efficient algorithm for
monotone functions and more recent work
uh bklt and Gupta manage has um also
studied monotoneph but they achieve
optimal query complexity
so why did certification easy
for easy for monotone Ash
um why is this such a useful assumption
to make
first
uh it's easy to check whether s is a
certificate so as I said before in
general this is co-np complete
but for monotonef
um let's suppose f of x is equal to one
the argument's submetric if f of x is
equal to zero we can simply
um fix the coordinates of s to agree
with X and say all other coordinates to
zero
then if this still equals one by
monotonicity no matter how we set the
coordinates outside of s this will
always equal one so all we have to do is
check this one input where we've
set um all of s complement to be zero
um check whether that equals one and if
that's true then s is a certificate so
in this way monotonicity changes a coin
P complete problem to one that we can
check with one simple query
next minimality suffices
so what do I mean by that
um a minimal certificate is one where if
you drop any coordinate it's no longer a
certificate note that a minimal
certificate is not necessarily a minimum
certificate there could be a very short
certificate that involves
um entirely different coordinates you
can think of minimal certificates it's
local Optimum whereas the minimum is the
global Optimum
um in general there can be a minimalist
a minimal certificate with length that's
practically n
um even though the certificate
complexity is order login so
in general you can have really long
minimal certificates and still
um be nowhere clear close to what's
Optimum
um so why is minimality sufficient for
monotone functions
um again we're gonna suppose that f of x
is equal to one
um uh and suppose we have a minimal
certificate s
note that s has to contain all ones
because if it contains a zero we could
drop that uh we could drop that Zero
from the certificate and it'd still be a
certificate by monotonicity
um and that would violate minimality so
any minimal certificate contains all
wants and similarly any minimum
certificate will also contain all ones
so s might not be a minimum certificate
for this input that um I have on the on
the left but replace everything outside
of s with a zero and it's still a
minimal certificate for this new
um input X star but now it's also a
minimum certificate for this new x-star
why is that
um a minimum certificate must be all
ones so it must be a subset of s uh and
any strict subset of s is not a
certificate because s is minimal uh thus
s is the minimum certificate
so we've seen how useful a simplifying
assumption like monetizenicity is for
this problem and we've also seen how
intractable the general problem is
however we'd still really like to
understand general f because real world
examples aren't always going to be
monotone they might be arbitrarily
complex
so here we study
um general f
uh so for general f we need some other
way to get around intractability
we'll use an MP Oracle in the language
of complexity Theory we study this
problem's difficulty relative to an MP
Oracle uh I'll be representing the
Oracle as the octopus that correctly
predicted results of the World Cup but
if you prefer you can think of it as a
stat solver instead it's up to you
so here is the algorithmic problem
revised to include our MP Oracle it's
exactly the same as before except that
now of course we have access to an MP
Oracle to help us solve our problems
so we have two main results a new
algorithm and a new hardness result
first I will talk about the new
algorithm
so we're trying to find an upper bound
here for the difficulty of this problem
so from first principles let's try and
figure out its complexity
as I stated before the problem is not MP
assuming p is not equal to MP
and I also claim that it's pretty simple
to see that um this problem is in mp to
the MP
we can simply guess a certificate and
use the MP Oracle to verify that it is
indeed a certificate
so there's quite a gap between p and NP
to the MP so how do we figure out
exactly where certification lies
you might think that the problem is MP
to the MP complete
um its most natural formulation involves
two quantifiers so here I've written
that out there exists a set s such that
f of x star is equal to F of Y for all y
that agree with X star on S we have
there exists and for all y so you might
expect okay maybe
here we formulated this problem it has
two quantifiers maybe it's empty to the
empty complete
uh our first main result counters this
intuition and we give a BPP to the MP
algorithm for certification
next we provide a lower Bound for
instance wide certification so what is
instant swad certification
um it's exactly the same as before but
we've replaced the certificate
complexity with its instance-wise
counterpart
um remember that cert sub f of x star
it's simply the length of the shorted
certificate for x-star
um before we were taking a maximum
overall X but here we just are
considering our specific input X star
in contrast to the previous slide this
problem is NP to the MP hard
um and that's the the major uh result
that we that we proved
uh in fact we show that
third sub f of x star is optimally NP to
the NP hard to approximate
so what exactly do I mean by that
um it's empty to the MP hard to
distinguish between yes there is a uh
size case certificate for F's value on
f-star and no every certificate for F's
value on X star head sides almost n to
be more precise K times n to the one
minus Epsilon
so there are hardness results for higher
levels of the polynomial hierarchy but
there are very few hardness of
approximation results
and there are even fewer optimally hard
to approximate results where we have
this optimal
um ratio between the yes and no caves
excuse me this work in addition to being
interesting in the context of
certification adds a natural problem to
a very fairly small group of problems
that are known to be hard to approximate
in higher levels of the polynomial
hierarchy
and that's all for me uh thank you so
much for listening